[Music]
hey what's up my name's daniel lee and
i'm amanda and this is this is our
second home guys this is our second home
so you might be thinking what do you
mean your second home well we're going
to be explaining on a house tour so
should we should we walk around show
them what's what this is a beautiful
home in beckensfield we've had this
place now for about 12 months so we're
going to walk you around show you around
the gardens show the inside the
interiors and also explain to you why we
have more than one house so let's go
so first question the thing that people
are going to really want to know is
amanda why
do we have more than one house we
actually rent another one as well
it's open yes it is we rent another one
just down the road why do we have so
many houses well we have different
houses different children in different
houses hello
are you looking after the place
yes she is all right let's go through
and see what we think the reason we have
different houses
is because
hello
you'll find out in a minute um
okay so this is the uh what did you call
this room the foyer the foyer the
entrance the foyer the entrance you know
that you're doing well
when the foyer to your house
is bigger than the living room of the
house you grew up in that's when you
know you're doing well hey kitty hello
how are you guys doing
do you like it here
question which house do you love more
this house
or the other house
oh yeah
but we just bought the other house ruby
what about you luke do you prefer this
house or the other house
yeah my man
3 million pound well spent there we go
so yeah this is the garden this is the
back garden beautiful i like the fact
that the whole we always like houses
where the garden circles the house yeah
when you can walk around the house we
love that it's just a nice you know what
i love as well i love the fact that all
you can see is fields but you can't even
see them because the trees are kind of
blocking them complete privacy if you
can't dance around naked in your back
garden then it is not private enough
samuel's naked a lot at home oh oy
hot tub we've nev i'll tell you
something a
fact about the top tub we've never been
in it
no we haven't and we haven't been in our
swim spa at the other house for six i
know i know trying to drag her in we
agreed it was like a thirty thousand
pound swim spa and what was the
agreement when we bought the swim spa
but any time samuel asked me to go in
i'd have to say yeah because she was
like i want to buy this bar i was like
30 grand baby you're gonna need if we're
gonna spend 30 grand you need to go in
it whenever i say and she's like got it
do you go in whenever i say
not all the time no i do love it i do
but sometimes you'll ask me like 10
o'clock at night and it's like do you
really want to get out of bed which is
well we are a sucker for palm trees
we just got some new palm trees um check
out
check out this man so nice
i love it
it feels like we're on holiday all over
again i know
my whole life just feels like a holiday
i love that this house
has this like annex
the garage
because you know so handy that's the
only thing i feel like it has over our
house nanny cleaners guests yeah outside
separate house
so you've got like a triple garage
and this upstairs is just like a
basically a big bedroom it's not really
worth going up it's nothing fancy we are
trying to get planning permission at the
moment aren't we we are yes struggling
struggling as a [ __ ] oh my gosh i'm so
surprised though but yeah so what we're
trying to do out of the house so we're
trying to add an annex above our
double we have a double garage and we're
trying to get planning permission to
just basically do this yeah but because
there's a listed building not too far
it's been a bit of a pain but it will
add so much value to the house if we
don't manage to get into an annex we're
going to keep it as it is and turn it
into a recording studio videos so like
this i love the views as well man i know
those fields it's just great it is
gorgeous those trees don't even look
real do they
it looks like a painting yeah it does so
picture pictures
it's nice coming here we don't come here
all the time we just kind of come here
sometimes but
what are you thinking like it i
absolutely love it i love this entrance
area oh wow hello matey
wow mommy's in demand wow
oh beautiful come to daddy one two three
she don't want daddy
everyone wants a bit of mama okay come
on then
wow oh
anyway this is the lounge welcome folks
and we didn't we've not even finished
like even half of downstairs we've got a
a games room
what do you call this room it's like a
snug cinema
cinema is pushing it
i mean you know there's a projector
there's a screen we do watch movies here
sometimes a prayer room
a little office room this was going to
be an office but i just didn't need it
because i don't really my work isn't
really office
my office is my car you know when i'm
out on the road
so we'll take you to the games room
the game's room is pretty cool it's just
nice like when you're entertaining when
you have people over
like even during the parties some people
will break off into here
first person go on show us your first
person to potter ball wins i must say
i'm not good at
snooping is it a disclaimer yeah
oh
you go
i've set you right up man
i can tell just by the way you're
holding it oh no
oh no
that oh
i don't hang in here that much okay i
thought that was going to go in as well
oh yes
when i was
16 years old
my job was i used to clean snooker
tables
um i used to get paid
30 pounds a week did you know this yeah
yeah 30 pounds a week
and i used to have to go in every day
for two hours wow 30 pounds a week which
is 36 day 120 pounds a month
damn
that wouldn't even that wouldn't even
cover
the the electricity on this house
in fact barely early
but anyway now instead of cleaning it
mandy cleans it for free
[Laughter]
right let's go
the kitchen's really nice it's so
light and bright there's windows on
every wall in the kitchen which is quite
nice believe it or not though the thing
that costs more than anything is having
like furniture in different places like
this the furniture is expensive um
okay why don't you tell them because
some people might be thinking why the
heck do you have multiple houses so
what was the initial reason that we
took this house because we rent this
house yeah we went in this house
initially what happened was we were in
the process of buying our house and we
didn't know if it was going to go
through or you know we got such a good
deal on the house okay we were buying it
for three million yeah but we were
thinking
the seller might pull out yeah if the
seller pulls out not only will we have
lost the house but we're gonna strike
it's hard to rent mansions there's not
many mansions like this for rent so we
were thinking let's rent this place as a
backup and just in case house yeah
just in case house yeah but then when
our house completed we liked it so much
you know we stayed here and we just use
it for meetings i run a lot of events we
have get-togethers with our academy
students and drinks and gatherings and
it's just a nice because when you've got
like kids at home and stuff you know
it's not idealistic no it's not ideal
just having one address yeah so um
yeah it's nice but i love this so
upstairs man this is three stories we
have a total of how many bedrooms i
think six bedrooms you think six depends
what you include as a bedroom we've only
had the house a year i mean how are we
supposed to know how many bedrooms it's
got so these are the rooms
double rooms every room's double every
room is ensuite every room has got a
beautiful view
this is normally where the kids stay
it's not really like a home like we
don't stay here that often we like our
house
we come here quite a bit
but we don't normally sleep here do we
no we don't and when we're not here
we're either if i'm working here or
we're running an event or we're renting
it out to our staff or
whoever um our room
do you wanna show them our room oh the
master bedroom this this room is killer
like oh my goodness we've never shown
this room ever before to anyone so here
we are
living space amazing amazing we don't
need to leave this room that's why we
don't know how many bedrooms there are
because we just stay in here the kitchen
the games room in this room that's all
you need in the house so yeah nice
eating area nice seating area and then
you've obviously got the bedroom space
yeah nice and big yep the best part of
the room oh yeah balcony right this
balcony here you can't beat this
[Music]
this is the best
we sit out here often in the mornings
when we stay here we just come out have
breakfast out here um we can literally
check up on the kids
what do you call this a
skyline a skylight highlight skylight
whatever it's called it's beautiful
it's just beautiful man the views as
well
it's just such a nice space
yeah
i love this
this is the best thing about the house
it is it is such a nice feature the bad
part about where this house is
location wise you do get planes
true we live no planes yeah
that is true we were driving we were
driving to this house uh the other day
we had an event on i think i did i don't
know if i told you the story but there
was um quite a few cars and it was sort
of like blocking the road and this
really angry car came beeping the horn
trying to get past and uh and we were
like sorry sorry elliot jumps out right
elliot's my best friend i'm his best man
at his wedding coming up elliot jumps
out the car he's like sorry sorry the
guy's so angry he gets out the car right
he's like come on right the guy who's
shouting said come on
is russell brand no way russell brat now
i didn't actually
hear everything i was in the house i
heard commotion everyone said to me
russell brands losing his [ __ ] russell
brandon right i don't know i'm sure
russell brown was just being nice but
nudging everybody
so there's a lot of celebrities living
around this area we're in beckenfield
and um you know the houses are all kind
of like mansions this mansion galore
this house is worth probably four
million probably i'd say that yeah the
house we bought we bought it for three
million if we get planning permission
and we do the relevant extensions and
develop it if we get the balcony on
stuff that we're trying to get on we're
going to add value to that that's why we
didn't want to buy a house like this
that's already completely ready wanting
to add a bit of value i think our house
will probably worth about 4 million
so
the houses here are expensive but worth
it you wouldn't want to buy momentum out
no what about our landlord what was he
thinking i know i don't know i guess
they thought they were going to come
back to the house the funny thing is
tell them about the landlord where we
ended up and what happened so our
landlord lived in singapore who we love
by the way if you're watching this we
love you great landlord they were and
they were just going to go for like two
years so we were renting the house short
term
and then on my birthday we found out
that they were going to be moving back
to the uk and we were thinking oh no but
we love the house we don't want to lose
the house the house wasn't on the market
it was their family home that they
bought literally just for them
everything's for sale yeah so then we
just put in our best offer and then they
accepted it and we were just like yes
but then because we knew how amazing the
house was and we thought they might pull
out that's why we ended up with this
yeah but then they ended up
moving into one of our other rental
properties yeah yeah how crazy so we're
renting this other place there must be
and they they said that they were
getting loads of posts for us
in another house so we we just dominate
this whole part of buckinghamshire we've
got eight pieces of land eight pieces of
land around here that we're currently
trying to get plenty permission to build
some houses so buckingham [ __ ] we love
it there's money to be made here but you
don't want to buy a house like this
especially not for investment purposes
you want to rent a place like this with
the profits from the land developments
and property investments you're doing
so love it
bathroom's nice walk-in wardrobe i'm not
going to take you in the walking
wardrobe because all you're going to see
in there is what
samuel's polo [ __ ] my polo shirts no
bling no fancy stuff you have like one
or two nice bags but nothing too fancy
but just my polo shirts that's it and
then uh
nice master bath master bathroom yeah
it's just so nice isn't it it is yeah
it's hot
it's hard to go on holiday when you live
in houses like this i know because we
always say when we travel the hotel we
stay in has to match or be way better
than our bedroom at home so it's quite
hard usually because then we're so picky
aren't we well yeah because if we're on
holiday we want it to be nicer than our
normal home but finding hotels that are
nicer because you know we have obviously
we have butlers that come down and cook
for us here we have cleaners we have a
nanny
so going away on holiday to a hotel when
you're in a small little room like it's
it's like why are we even doing this
in lockdown we were loving it man we
were just like yes
three houses
but anyway i hope you guys like this i
hope you guys like the house and don't
forget as well like everything that
we're showing you now our whole
lifestyle was built off of 10 years
grit and hustle so you know let it be
inspiration because you know i was
cleaning snooker tables like i said you
know like 13 years ago so
we've done wow
this baby's the brains behind the
operation
let's go
so we've shown you two rooms yes and
there's two more rooms here and here and
they're pretty similar to the first room
that we showed you double rooms with an
ensuite so this room's pretty nice
oh yeah
this room is like
nice again
big room
tv got a little office area over there
sixth room here
so this is it folks
this is the sixth room
the views again like you can just look
out and see fields
you can look out here
see our jacuzzi
oh man i love this house it is amazing
now we're not going to be keeping this
house for a whole much lot longer we've
just taken on a new contract from the
same agent
for another house down the road the
reason we didn't show this house tour
sooner was because we just didn't you
know we kind of like to keep a level of
privacy yeah so we didn't show this
sooner but as we've got another house
now maybe in a year or two we'll show
that other house but all i'll say is it
makes this house look rubbish
boom
so yeah you'll get that next year or the
year after
oh man so favorite thing about the house
favorite thing is definitely the balcony
in the master bedroom yeah and for me
favorite thing i love the look as well
when you come up
just it just looks great it feels like a
dream well i hope you've enjoyed
watching guys comment down below which
your favorite room was what was your
favorite bit but also don't forget you
want to rent the house or buy a house
like this
it's it's all right to watch and to
visualize but you've got to put the work
in so if you want to find out how to
invest in property smart so that you can
afford your passive income to pay for a
house like this then you need to
subscribe to the channel and watch more
content in how we've actually built up
our wealth would you agree amanda yes i
agree you're the best wife in the world
you're the best family in the world
should we say bye bye
see you next time